pues como bien lo mencionaba su raúl va
a haber conversaciones acerca de cómo
incluir a los jóvenes en las decisiones
climáticas porque como bien sabemos en
estas cumbres ellos no tienen poder de
voto sin embargo si van a ser él tiene
en el día de hoy dedicado a escuchar a
ser escuchados y hay varios eventos
tanto en la zona azul que es donde se
llevan a cabo las reuniones de alto
nivel como en la zona verde que es una
zona de más actividades de la sociedad
civil
mañana sábado es la marcha del día
global por la justicia climática y se
espera que en esa marcha haya unas
50.000 personas en la ciudad de glasgow
y esperamos estar aquí en la calle
reportando sobre ella